You are listening to radio lab radio from W N y.
S. E. N. N. P. R. Who's the gentleman we're on the air with? Not, oh,
there's going to be two of us. So one of them is named Jab. That's not me.
His name is Jad.
Like his parents call him Jad Jad but if jad really had they been drinking?
No, they live in these [inaudible] so we're going to begin the show with this
delightful duo. I'm Julie. Julie Moss. I'm Wendy Gwendy Ingram. Hi Julie.
Hi Wendy. Hi Jad. They've been friends for a really long time.
Remember that one time you bought all that? Everything in a tube.
They both like to travel.
They both like to shop and they both like to run really long distances until
they collapse usually in front of millions of people. Now, Wendy,
Wendy was a classic athlete from day one who was apparently born this way.
Her mother tells me how she had to channel her energy into sports. A. Yeah.
I always considered myself a science project.
What do you mean we, we'd been created. We have hands, feet.
We have a mind. We have lungs, we have a heart. Let's see what it can do. Wendy,
we're very opposite in that, that Julie,
Julia is an entirely different story and we're going to tell you that story in
just a moment. But first we should say this is Radiolab. I'm Chad Apple,
Ron and I'm Robert Krulwich topic today is limits,
limits of the body.
Rest right there in the limits of the brain and finally the limits of what we
can know about everything.
Julie,
how did you get interested in this race that you're about to tell us about?
Was it like a, like an impulse or something? Well, no,
it was a requirement to graduate. I had, I had to do a, um,
it's called a senior senior project.
I went to cal poly San Luis Obispo in California and I, I was a PE major,
which now I said, you mean? Yeah. And I that was just by default.
I was a California surfer girl. I started surfing at 14,
but I needed a senior project and there I was in, um,
1981. Yeah,
watching TV instead of studying. Then
in on comes ABC wild rose
sports brought to you by advisor voice
from Hawaii and I watched it and it just sucked me in.
This must have been like really early ironman. Oh yeah.
I think it was the fourth one and I thought it's in Hawaii. It's great.
I know my mom will pay for it because this is,
I have to do this project for school and so I started doing research on it and
this, just so we know this is you, you, you swim, you bike, you run.
That's the order. You swim 2.4 miles,
you ride 112 miles and then you run a marathon. So it was,
wait a second though. Go ahead.
That seems like a major decision to want to go 140 I mean were you at triathlete
type person at that point in your life? Had you ran a marathon before?
It was conceptual. Those were just the distances. Those were numbers.
That wasn't reality. It was just you were in Hawaii.
By the time I got off the plane to do the Ironman,
I still hadn't completed the total distance that I'd need to do on the bike or
the swam. Oh my God. Wow. But I wasn't going over there to be competitive.
I was going over there to do this event, have fun in Hawaii,
and then I'll write up some sort of bogus, you know,
physiological consequences or something. But I really just,
I thought I was taking the easy way out.
When you got off the bus or you walked into the room where the other ones were,
did you suddenly think, oh yeah. I mean people were taking it very seriously.
People had coordinated outfits and I thought,
I am feeling a little like, um, the country mouse, you know? So I,
I think when race day rolled around, it was,
it was sort of my day to get through and never do again. I mean, it was really,
this is a onetime thing, so let's show, should we run the race? Yeah. So, okay,
let's just, you do the first two legs to swimming and then the biking.
I'm doing really well. You see me on the bike, I'm riding along,
I mean from the old coverage of ABC. I'm smiling at the camera.
I'm certainly not in an aerodynamic position.
Why would you want to be all crouched over when you keep sitting up smiling?
That was your beauty queen. I was doing parade waves.
I really was loving the attention. And, um,
I had a snickers bar early on the bike ride,
and I keep thinking if I'd only eaten that snickers bar instead of throwing it
away, ABC came up on a camera on there.
I was trying to open this melted snickers bar with my teeth and all of a sudden
there's a camera and it's like, oh my gosh,
I don't want to be messy on national TV. So I ditched this,
this beautiful snickers bar and you know, yeah, yeah.
Okay. Skipping to the third leg of the race, Julie's through the swim.
She's through the 112 mile bike ride onto the marathon.
I came off the bike. Uh, they told me there's a woman ahead of you at,
she was a top notch cyclist. Oh, so you were in second place? Yeah. Whoa, Whoa,
Whoa, whoa. How could this happen? I was doing really well.
And I started on the run and the one gal who had had a great bike ride had a,
uh, an Achilles injury and sure enough, five, I think about eight miles or so,
I caught her and there I am in the lead. Wow.
And all of a sudden it was a little, um, things started to shift.
I'm, I'm, I'm good at something
and somebody is trying to take it away from me.
And that was the woman who was in second place, Kathleen McCartney.
And even though she was a mile away,
it felt like she was breathing down my neck and trying to take something that
now I was becoming very attached to.
I was also starting to fall apart physically. What were those early signs?
I'm cramping and a feeling that you weren't digesting your food,
that everything was sort of sitting there, sloshing around Wendy's laughing.
If she's good, this is serious moment and she's laughing about it.
Nanny case
Sinally Julie makes it to the last little EDBD stretch of the race.
Probably about, oh,
about 400 meters from the finish and she's still in first place to do Julie,
let's do this. I'm actually, as we're talking, I'm watching you on a Youtube,
oh stinker. But I just wanted to take me into your head
these final moments cause it's, it's just like,
it's unwatchable but you can't turn away. Yeah, it's a train wreck.
So I'm looking at you now and you're running and it's dark as people like on
both sides cheering you until you're running and then you're slowing down
and you really slowing down and you're walking a little bit like you're on
stilts and then great here.
Your legs give out. They give out
and I couldn't get back up.
I mean I get up and my legs wouldn't work.
[inaudible].
So I actually, I sort of laid there on the ground and um,
I figured out if I put my arms in front of me and leaned on my arms,
they would sort of form like a tripod and I could sort of lean on my arms and
kind of got one leg up and one leg up and,
and kind of staggered to a walk and started walking again.
All right, now you're walking again, but you're like junk monkey. Yeah.
Really wobbly. Yeah. No.
All this time your conscious that number two is getting closer and closer.
Are you, are you out? Are you conscious? I've heard all, oh yeah. Oh yeah.
And I had to keep finding a way to keep going and my thought was,
this is mine. Oh, you just fell again.
Oh yeah,
yeah. See this is the one that gets me right here.
You fall down and it's in your arms. Go back. It's like you're dying. Yeah.
[inaudible]
and um,
as I was putting one hand in front of the other, I saw this,
this pair of tennies go by and a these legs and I thought that's her.
She's gone by me
and it was just, I just thought I quit.
Okay.
I just thought, I can't say it on national public radio, but effort,
effort and all of a sudden,
okay,
there's this voice that just said, get up, get up.
Just keep moving forward.
I could see the finish line about 10 feet in front of me and I thought Getta I
cannot, I can't get up again. I really, I'd get up. Do not think I've,
I've sort of worn out that tactic. Get up, but I can crawl
well fine.
And I crawl and so here I am coming along and,
and the TV, camera lights, you're blinding me in. No one's helping her.
My life was going to be different. I mean I felt my life changing.
I made a deal with myself. A deal was struck and I don't care if it hurts,
I don't care if it's messy. I don't care how it looks. I would finish,
I would finish, finish
[inaudible]
so Julie Moss crawls the last 10 feet of the race, literally an inch at a time.
that whole time the cameras are on her and they capture everything.
[inaudible]
and I mean everything. Yeah. I, um,
I pooped my pants on national TV.
It doesn't get more shameful that from that when d teases me all the time,
you know, you were [inaudible]
chocolate mess from, you know, one way or the other.
You can get up there and do this next thing. But it was, it was a,
it was a pivotal moment in my life and to the stage. Julie says,
the person she is now,
it all began with that voice that, uh,
that I hadn't ever called upon that just said, keep moving forward. Well,
that's the thing that gets to me is like, it didn't say to you, you can't, it,
it actually said exactly the opposite. I'm isn't that cool?
I would have thought it would have said, stop. Come on. Stop.
Well, I doubt you. Look [inaudible]
ego. That's your ego that will come in and sabotage your real self.
There is no limit. You know? I really believe that and I just,
I absolutely do. No, no limit. Nope.
[inaudible] nope,
nope. [inaudible] yeah, no.
Let's take seriously what Julia Mazda said. No limits.
I think she meant the psychologically yes. I mean they are obviously limits.
If she, well, yes, they could die. You could die. Yeah. But short of that,
you would say it is her muscles that are determining the limits. Right, exactly.
And the sale your muscle cells. Yeah. Let's just question that for a second.
Let me introduce you to it. To a
guy. His name is, uh, what's his name? David Joe.
His name is David Jones. Hi. Hi. Miss Him.
He's retired physiologist and much point in university and he's got a slight
condition that interferes with his speech, just so you know. Okay. Anyways,
he did a study, two studies actually that involved bikers.
He's on experiments likeness.
He'll have these people ride stationary bikes for really long distances. Yeah.
All the while he'll shoot their muscles full of sugar, like with an IV.
[inaudible] actioning it.
Extremely high levels of [inaudible] guys in the plant. How much?
Like a whole energy drinks worth of sugar straight into their blood. Oh,
more than that. Formally and prominent several energy drinks. Oh No.
Theoretically,
if it's your muscles that are controlling how far and fast you bike,
you should get this injection and just be like,
I shouldn't be performing miracles. That's fine. But it never works.
It never works. Yeah. People who,
who have sugar in their muscles do the same as people who don't. That's not,
it doesn't work at all, man. I'm seeing their difference now, the Holden's Whoa,
bad news for sugar.
And what it suggests is that our muscles have way less to do with our limits
than we think, which raises the obvious question. What is making the difference?
So now I'm going to tell you about the second study, which I completely like.
Find mind blowing. Oh, that's a hard study to summarize, but I'm gonna try.
Okay. You, so you with me, with you so far you haven't started yet though.
That totally is a good place to be. I need your full participation and interest.
Okay. Okay.
So he does a study where he puts a bunch of bikers on bikes and he has them
peddle a lot, is about 40 kilometers, long distance now he's got two groups.
Each group gets an energy drink,
which they sort of have to drink while biking while biking,
except that they don't drink it. The rule is they don't actually drink it.
They just swish it in their mouth and ascension out. Swish and spit.
That's right. That's what they do. Swish, spit, bike, swish, spit by. Whoa.
Wouldn't want to be the towel guy in this particular experiment. Well,
I really have scientists with buckets who just stand next to them and then I
spent in an apartment. Okay,
so half the people get real energy drink to swish and spit.
Yeah.
Half the people get fake energy drink to swish and spit and I might of times the
same and nobody knows who's getting what. It's the normal line.
So you would think in this scenario that nobody should get any benefit from this
because no one's actually drinking the drink, nothing's getting into the body.
Or let's say like the taste creates a placebo effect.
Well then everybody should get the placebo effect equal.
Everybody should get it. But here's the thing. Only the people who switched,
switched, not drank, but switched the real energy drink. Got a boost.
Oh, how much of a boost in seven minutes or a couple of minutes. Whoa.
That's a lot. Yeah, I'm minutes Max demonstrating, you know,
finishing [inaudible] lost. Yeah. So let me think here,
but don't say anything for a minute. Let me think about this.
So maybe some thing in the first set of athletes who got the real drink,
something inside the new something.
Here's the big theory. Do you want the little theory of the big one first? Well,
I'd like the big theory briefly. Okay. The big one briefly.
There's an idea that's been floating around for a while called the central
governor theory, which has it inside your head.
There's this little circuit which just starting to see on brain scans,
there's this little circuit that governs your energy supply and when it feels
like you're in danger of running
low, it'll trigger signals of pain
to be sent to your body to try and get you to rest.
Now what scientists are finding is that this governor circuit is really
conservative.
It'll send you a pain to try and get you to stop way before you are out of
juice. So with your a fuel tank, they would flash e e for empty,
but you get a quarter tank left.
So what might be happening with these bikers is it the sugar is landing on their
tongue.
[inaudible]
the tongue sees the sugar, sends a message to the brain.
The governor sees this message and says, Oh,
if we're about to get some energy then it's okay for you to spend some energy.
And let me just give you some from my secret stash over here.
And so you feel a boost
[inaudible]
the conjecture here is you have a reservoir of extra stuff,
but it is so deeply disguised that you can't even know that it's there.
Exactly. And to skip to the punchline, when you feel tired,
Mr k [inaudible] not just tired, when you are dead spent. Well you are spent.
Yeah. Which does not feel like a subjective thing at all.
That feels like an objective reality. You are done. Well in fact,
at that moment, maybe you're not.
Maybe you're just feeling the effects of that little governor lying to you. Uh,
which raises the question, what if you could live back to her
then, how far could you go?
So with all that in mind, I'm going gonna kick it up a notch.
Let me tell you about this competition called the ride across America.
It should really be called the ride into the fire depths of despair.
But we're going to call it a the right across quite the zing that the sponsor
wanted. The, those where I live, Wrigley's smear with go.
We heard about this first from a reporter named Daniel Coil.
So what is the right across America?
It is basically, it's an insane event. You,
you'd get on a bike in California and you bike across the country, 3000 miles,
the equivalent of four Mount Everest.
And they don't sleep at all. No. They will sleep.
They'll sleep a an hour a day, two hours a day, um,
hour a day. Yeah. So if, if this is a 10 day race,
they will sleep for 10 hours over the length of the race. Yeah.
It's a race that is designed to reveal what human limits are.
Who Does it? Can you describe the kinds of people who are attracted to this? No,
I think they come from all walks of life. They come from all over the globe.
It's a really interesting cross section. We actually got curious about this.
So we sent our producer, Lulu Miller to track down a few of these guys.
Two guys. Who'd you find? Well, the first one? Yes. His name is Patrick.
Patrick. You say I'm 47 years old from France. He's the
rookie. Had you done any kind of long distance cycling before? No. No, no, no,
no. He's actually a scientist. [inaudible] yeah, got a wife. Two kids. Okay.
And then we've got the champion. Okay. Hello? You right here.
So this is your aerobic.
He's won this thing four times and on the back he's a killer.
My Body [inaudible] I can go also in the rain or cold or the heat job as he's a
soldier implied by a Slovenian army. What else? What would you like to know?
Okay,
2005 wow.
This start with Sydney in San Diego. Touched
[inaudible] like 20 people or a hundred people. 25,
I think to the tape you're hearing right now is actual footage from that deck
got backdrop turned out the year he did it.
There was actually a film crew there following every single ride and so I was
really scared and scared him. Not Uri though. No,
he's just in front of Patrick. I really, uh, I would say in English, uh,
I'm literally shoring myself. [inaudible]
[inaudible]
it's easy. You just start your engine and go.
Yeah.
For me and c site, they didn't know what to expect.
I was feeling very consultative.
I have the back of the back.
14 states, 3000 miles to go. They don't go very fast.
They'll cross the country going about 13, 14 miles an hour,
which any 11 year old couldn't ride for a Taco.
The difference is that they just told stop seven hours later.
California desert, it's really hot.
My Watch says 109 degrees. We're in the shade and the car,
this is Steve Toady,
the camera guy following Patrick in a van [inaudible] out here climbing a hill.
I've never experienced this kind of temperature.
Do you have any hubby then and 10 Friday night,
then 150 miles later,
Arizona running hills since it
200 300 million.
Then the sign is rising for
500 it's 10 very hot
then correct.
The mountains and the big mountains. You're using the lead.
He's just crested the top of the 12 mile climb.
It was during the middle of the night. It was just raining,
heavy rain. It begins to coast downward sanding could without Beverly
and after two kilometers I was completely frozen,
shaking like I was electrical. Your bed is like a hamburger. Oh yeah.
I mean it's all red. You don't have any skin at all. I mean,
the pike is the most efficient machine for creating suffering ever.
The pressures on your hands, the pressure is on your neck.
This British guy named Chris Hopkinson halfway through the race and his neck was
just given out. People whose necks have given out,
we'll take duct tape and literally tie their heads up.
They'll, they'll put a core to the back of their helmet and then pin it,
say to their belt, Jesus, God. So that they can look, cause they're,
they can no longer hold their heads up. God,
the is like waves,
you know, and I don't know why he's dead, but it is, uh,
it's like waste. It's coming. Can, it's going.
It's a WHO's going to lose assuming that the central governor circuits inside
the heads of all these riders are creating those waves of pain.
How do they soldier on? How do they ignore it?
Well, I asked them that and they each sort of have different techniques.
So Patrick,
just start shouting back at it. Literally.
Yeah. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Yeah. Any Uri? Well,
he gets his crew to come up alongside him and Blair
[inaudible]
Slovenian war songs speak us. Yeah, very loudly.
Is that what we're hearing? It is. This is him on his bike during the race.
[inaudible]
but then they hit the halfway point. I don't know if you've been to Ken before.
I don't know. It's awful.
Scenery gets really monotonous and you don't have any sightseeing,
nothing more than that.
They've gone over a thousand miles without sleeping basically.
And that's where we see the sort of really interesting stuff start to happen.
It's here that we can catch a glimpse of the hidden potential of the human body.
If you've done everything, if you've handled the heat and hydration,
if your infrastructure is solid, all the stress goes to the last point,
which is the mind. Um, it,
Ken's very suddenly it was doc.
I were in a forest and very quickly the environment got very um,
accuracy. He said he saw shadows running across the road.
It looked like the trees were trying to reach out to get him.
I was starting to have nightmares, but I was awake.
These kinds of hallucinations are just a fact of the race.
People seeing secret code in the cracks of the road,
riders jumping off their bikes to square off and fight mailboxes.
It's what breaks a lot of people. Strangely,
these kinds of hallucinations might be the very key to Uri.
I saw every single,
I mean a lot of like monsters like zombies.
He's gonna attack, you know? And why would that help him? Well for me,
it was really think about why the central governor's in place or the system
that's designed to always keep an emergency stash of energy there for you should
you ever need it.
So those feelings of pain are really just a way of safeguarding that last little
stash of energy that you could use if you absolutely had to. Yeah.
Like if your life was on the line or something, that's right,
but what if you are convinced and therefore your central governor was convinced
that your life really was on the line
that year when you got to Ohio, he, he hallucinated that there were
Lucia [inaudible], Dean's or Afghan horsemen chasing him. Yeah,
with a gun, with just shot gun. And I said to bikers to fate,
they out of shooting gas, come on, come on, two 17 we are soldiers.
Do something to this idea or attack.
The interesting thing about that is that is the way in which his team sees him
hallucinating. Lose your hygiene and their reaction is, oh yeah,
we see them to go your, to your mind when you are escaped, why?
Because they're gaining on us. They're gaining on it. It's funny, you know,
but for me it was not funny.
They will use his hallucination as, as fuel and they,
they make no bones about it. And when you see that,
that's my dad's planning check, Uris, crew chief,
when you see him riding that fast after five,
six days almost dying on the bike and then suddenly he explodes,
your hair on your arm would go up on your neck would go up. And then, you know,
that's, that's why we are there because it's,
you don't want to miss that moment because this is something out of this world.
He says that during the hallucinations, I mean, the pain is gone. Does it go,
does it go away? Completely? Yeah.
But the tradeoff is that when he watches videos of himself like this punching
mailboxes and throwing his bike into a ditch, he says,
it's actually painful to watch. You know, it's really
tough for me to look into myself in this video was in these films. Uh, I'll do,
I might be going.
The reality is he's looking at a madman. It's not to me, that's,
that's not me. Yeah. See now I'm thinking like Daniel,
like if madness is the key,
right to tricking your central governor and to giving you access to the,
did that energy,
does that mean that if Robert and I went mad in that particular way that we
would suddenly be really athletic? I mean,
are there actually seriously cases like that mother was actually in the early 19
hundreds.
There was a doctor named Auguste [inaudible] who noticed a mental patient making
a leap in an asylum and he measured the leap and it compared rather favorably to
the world record at the time. Yeah.
And he was one of the early sort of propagators of this governor theory that Oh,
obviously this patient from whom all the sort of governors had been lifted was
capable of, um, a feat of astounding strength.
Absolutely. What happened at the end of the race? Well,
Harry wins. I won the Ram.
That's the sound team. And what about Patrick?
Well, let's rewind a couple of days.
He's just crossed the halfway point Mount Vernon, Kansas,
and he decides to hop off his bike, take a quick break. And he's in the van.
He checks his email just to give me some motivation and he sees an email from
one of his friends. He said, we're so sad that, uh, the Dr Breedlove accident,
Patrick had no idea what this guy was talking about,
but it appeared to suggest that one of the 25 riders,
a guy named Dr Bob Breedlove had just been hurt.
And so I asked when I'm a crew member, uh,
what happened was Dr Breedlove and he said, well, uh,
it got an accident and he died
on the race during the race. Yeah.
[inaudible] and so when he's, when he, when he told me this,
I mean, immediately I was, I was, I mean, I was, I was, I mean, I mean,
nothing is shocked, but, uh, I was done.
I understand Patrick. I feel bad too, obviously.
And so it's happened teeth today. The commandment tried to, to push me both.
They would be pointless to, to stop here where you have a wide shoulder,
a van right behind you, who's going to coat [inaudible] and, oh,
well, sorry. But a petri just fell down the road.
And so he's asking [inaudible] or even even even worst,
I have kids and I voice I went to, I went to found this phrase,
I understand Patrick put how far the next time station. Why don't we go there?
[inaudible] I don't want to continue that. That's what he said.
That's okay. I don't want to continue that. I'm just saying,
let's not throw in the towel just yet.
So after that, I mean, uh, I started writing again. [inaudible]
but uh, for them
it was a magical night is very, uh, very well, a beautiful night,
no class, nothing. And as always, his crews cheering him on,
trying to pump them up.
Yeah. Patrick, can I ask you why you're doing this? What?
Can I ask you a question or daddy want to talk?
Why are you doing this? But
he's not saying it anything back for hours.
And
then around one in the morning, Patrick says,
his mind just goes quiet, quiet,
completely silent.
Out of that silence, he said he heard a voice that said simply,
you stop. Stop.
I saw, that's what I did. I said,
I'm done. I'm done. Done.
You asked me a question on here. Remember why I was doing that? Yeah,
right there. Because we just wanted to test my limits.
Physical enemy and mental, and I touched twice this week,
yesterday morning and this morning and I don't want to read that again.
I quit. That's it.
Huh?
I'm trying to figure out who I would honor more. Yeah.
The winner of the race or the land who insisted on losing.
I'm 40 I've got kids. I identified more with the guy who stopped. Yeah. Yeah.
But I think also you,
you see the guy who wins and it makes you ask big questions about what's
possible. Yeah. Like how do you do that? Yeah.
I don't know that I'd want to be that guy or even hang out with them.
Probably like the second guy. I know. I'd like the second guy. Oh, Ben,
what do you think? I find myself looking at both of them,
kind of with my jaw on the floor.
[inaudible]
Daniel Coyle. His latest book is called the talent [inaudible].
Yeah, and a huge thanks to Stephen Auerbach who made the film bicycle dreams.
That's where all this footage came from.